it is a great honor to meet you I'm in
awe of anybody who's done so much for
ocean conservation I see one of your
constituents is coming I notice you know
doesn't seem that excited about meeting
the president this all should be that's
great great to see you you know there's
so many of your constituents who are out
there that most people don't even know
about I had a question for you and that
is what's it like going down a thousand
meters I'd love to show you I I mean
I've done some diving but I think right
around a hundred I kind of say okay it's
time to turn back but it must get pretty
dark down there most of life on Earth
lives in the dark red all of the time
because below a thousand feet it's dark
but life persists seven miles down yeah
and that's part of what is now you know
protected right so you're still diving
huh I'm still breathing
so of course I'm still how many dives
have you taken oh you know seven
thousand hours that's a lot of hours no
it's not but it think about it how
little of the ocean we still know yeah